chances with us in Nashville high chance
how are you
chance I'm had better days
uh-oh what's up well so I had a question
my question was how do I differentiate
myself to employers so I graduated from
with my a business degree in economics
may 2017 and I've been looking for work
ever since though I'm I graduated I was
on the Dean's List every single semester
save one of my college career and I
graduated kumoi they good for you
and they give you a little bit more of
my background since age 17 I've been
independent so I've worked my way in my
final year of high school and all four
years of my college lets them tough I
didn't get oh what do you want to do
I've trained what do I want to do I
trained to be a data analyst so I'd like
to get a job in that field okay all
right and what do you think that that
position is worth so the going market
rate for that median is $52,000 in their
salad mm-hmm that includes people with
experience that are not straight out of
college right no no that is for people
who were supposed to be said out of
college bachelor's degree to have zero
to one years of experience in the field
okay all right
because I've got some dad line analysts
here but and I knew they made more than
that but I was thinking so I'm just
wondering where you got that okay all
right cool well so first thing is go to
Ken Coleman
Ken Coleman's website the Ken Coleman
show or Ken Coleman calm either one and
you want to download his to PDFs there
how to distinguish yourself in the
interview process and also how to write
a resume that will actually get you an
interview now a couple things one most
employers unless they're like huge huge
companies
sadly really don't care about whether
you're on the Dean's List they really
don't care what your GPA was I'm glad
you did that it does indicate to me as
an employer that you're a smart guy but
truthfully all I care about is can you
do the work here that's what I care
about and to the extent that that
indicates you can do the work fine but
I'm going to be concerned about your
street-smart as well as your book smart
as to whether or not you can actually
pull that data up and use some common
sense to look at that data does that
make sense okay and so what any employer
I mean you've got a degree in econ you
know this what any employer is looking
for is a return on investment so they're
spending $60,000 on you that they want
to make six hundred from the data you
produce and so you've got to produce
data that gives them some kind of
insight into their business that causes
them to make money is that logical it
does okay so what are you doing what are
you doing for food to eat right now what
kind of what kind of just side you got a
side hustle or a part-time hustle or
something while you're trying to eat
right yeah so I finally receives
part-time employment this past June and
I'm a courier and so I deliver I deliver
pharmaceuticals to hospitals regional
hospitals and when I complete my runs
for the day I usually do door - oh I
deliver food not you okay so what are
you making how much money you remaining
how much money you're making it really
varies like roughly a month in a given
month what do you make roughly in a
given month roughly two thousand to
twenty thousand dollars okay cool half
of what your what your market value is
as a data analyst thing all right cool
all right here's a couple of ideas and I
don't know exactly how to help you break
through but I will tell you that you
need to be really really careful in the
language that you use your
and structure and so forth that
indicates when you're talking to a
potential employer that you're you don't
feel entitled to anything that you don't
feel put out you sound a little put out
that that somehow everybody hasn't lined
up to hire you okay
and if you transfer that to me in an
interview I'm not going to hire you
because what that tells me is a hiring
manager is nothing I'm do as an employer
is ever going to make you happy that's
what I hear okay and I understand your
frustration but I'm coaching you you
follow me okay so go in there and say
how can I add value not you owe me
something and I and you weren't saying
that overtly don't misunderstand me I'm
not being I'm not picking on you but
just be very careful that you're there
to serve when I have someone come in
here that says hey if you pay me 60 I'll
make you 600 not going to show you how
that's somebody that gets me at my
attention if I hire a sales rep and I'm
gonna pay them 10 percent commission
it's the same thing right I'm paying
them 60 I'm making they're bringing in
600 and gross revenues right and so I
can do that all day long if I think the
guy or gal can sell and so I can add
that salesperson that because they make
me more than they cost me and all of
that kind of thing so that's what you're
doing so a couple ideas to throw on top
of this number one three ideas number
one go to Ken Coleman's website and
download both of those PDFs they're
legit they will give you some good it's
how to win the interview and how to
write the perfect resume resumes are
worthless though without these other two
ideas idea number two you need to find
someone that works for the company I
don't care if it's in shipping that you
want to go to work for that you can make
a connection to a friend of a friend a
friend somebody you go to church with
whatever the deal right and so they can
walk your resume into HR or into the
hiring manager and say hey at least give
this guy a look because here let me give
you an example in our place we hired 200
people last year we're in your city we
had 15,000 applications
you get lost in that no matter how cool
you are that makes sense so I understand
that's how I got my current job I've
under a friend there you going to my
school yeah we got to get we got to get
just get just get me in the door now I'm
not asking you to hire me because this
guy I'm just asking to get me in the
door and let me get in front of them
okay then go in there you know all
polished up not weird not nerd it out
but I mean you you know you combed your
hair you brushed your teeth right you're
wearing a belt all that stuff you
dressed appropriately for that
particular workplace you go in there you
smile you look the guy in the eye and
you say I can add value all I need is a
shot I will bring in this company this
organization more than I cost and I can
show you exactly how I can do that and
as a matter of fact have done a little
bit of research on the company itself so
you can actually show them how you're
going to do that right say I've already
looked at this area over here I think I
could do something in that area then
last idea if none of that works here's a
way to break in offer to work for three
weeks for free I'm gonna come in here
and show you I'm gonna give you a sample
of this pizza and you're gonna want the
pizza I'm gonna give you a sample of
this biscuit you're gonna want the
biscuit and I just wanted I'm not trying
to be weird I'm trying to be strange but
I will come in here and work for three
weeks for free and get my feet in here
and show you guys that I will do
anything that it takes to add value to
this company more than this company pays
me I just want a chance to be a blessing
I want a chance to serve this
organization to sell organizations
customers and if you kind of come at it
that way with that attitude and you're
that body language that tonality with
your voice and it changes your sentence
structure and that's what I was kind of
coaching you on a little bit earlier
your sentence structure and the way you
approach the thing the emotion you're
using because I got to tell you they are
they're not hiring you based on your
degree they're not hiring you based on
where you went to school they're not
hiring you based on the Dean's List they
are not hiring you based on any of these
thing
they are only hiring you because they
can make more on you than you cost them
and that's what we're trying to convince
them of based on our education based on
the tools that are in our belt based on
the way I carry myself based on my
street smarts I got to tell you the fact
you've been independent on your own
since 17 is probably more impressive to
me as a presidential higher than the
Dean's List so there you go something to
think about
good job chance you got them if I can
help you further you call me back man
this is the Dave Ramsey show